well for one person this past year has
been truly out of this world NASA
astronaut scott Kelly has spent the past
three hundred forty two days on the
International Space Station that is the
longest stint ever for anyone aboard the
ISS his historic year in space and today
in Kelley's case NASA was blessed with a
scientific gold mine Kelly has an
identical twin so while Scott Kelly was
an orbit scientists observed his brother
Mark Kelly on the ground in September we
spoke with NASA's chief scientist dr.
Julie Robinson who told us why this is a
really big deal and we really need to
understand what it is about certain
astronauts that helps them to be
healthier when they're in space than
some of their colleagues that's really
important to know over the long term so
that we can send a crew that will be
safe and be able to complete a mission
like a mission to Mars Scott and Mark
are the first astronauts to step forward
and say study us while we're in orbit
use mark as a control back here on the
ground they're identical twins so that's
really powerful genetic data and that
really opens up a set of studies that
wouldn't have been possible before
beyond the science Kelly has become a
social media rock star this year sharing
breathtaking photos of a view that very
few used to be able to enjoy firsthand
that's been crucial to NASA's quest to
drum up public support for the space
program and perhaps it's working the
agency was flooded with over 18,000
would be astronaut job applications last
month for just 14 open spots